to our top story a rise in euthanasia
rates causing concern across our
community we thank you for joining us at
11 I'm Brian Loftis now statistics from
the animal foundation show the number of
dogs put down has nearly doubled from
this time last year sparking a planned
protest this week Sasha Loftus spoke
with the shelter City representatives
and experts to see why this could be
happening Sasha joins us live outside
the animal foundation now with more
Ryan dozens are set to be here outside
the animal foundation tomorrow
protesting that recent rise in
euthanasia rates so we talked to both
sides of the issue to see what solutions
could be had here
[Music]
side of the road by Lacey and Johnny
School that's what I knew we had really
had to spring into action the couple
found him a few weeks ago and took him
to the animal foundation to see if
anyone would claim him but they say when
they went back to check on McQueen the
dog was deemed aggressive and put on the
euthanasia list we thought we're gonna
lose him you know the couple was able to
get McQueen back and board him here
until he finds a forever home we are
constantly told that everything is fine
and we know it isn't but Las Vegas city
councilwoman Victoria Seaman says not
every story ends this way so she's
working hard to make change we as a city
are paying them extra money every year
to not euthanize and the euthanization
rates are just skyrocketed the animal
foundation's website shows a 91 spike in
dogs euthanized from 2021 to 2022 while
intakes only went up 8 percent
cats followed a similar Trend with a 61
increase when we reached out to the
shelter they provided this statement
which reads in part as an organizational
policy only animals not considered to be
healthy and or treatable are candidates
for Humane euthanasia euthanasia rates
vary depending on the population of
animals we serve 2022 was a tough year
for a lot of filters Dr Kate Hurley
director of the UC Davis shelter
medicine program says a lot of factors
can lead to trends like this the animals
keep coming
and like that's exigent they have to be
fed they have to be clean they have to
be cared for and if you get behind again
it's so easy for a negative cycle to get
started but councilwoman Seaman says
regardless of the reason she's pushing
for more transparency we need to start
looking at other uh solving the problem
in other ways than continuing what we're
doing now while Lacey and Johnny want
all animals like McQueen to have every
chance to find happiness someone is
going to discover this dog and just have
a best friend
now councilwoman Seaman said she did
request a city audit here at the animal
foundation about six months ago that has
not happened now the schools tell me
that that the dog that they rescue did
get proper treatment here at the animal
foundation proper medical treatment when
he was admitted now as for that full
shelter statement we have that right now
on our website 8newsnow.com reporting
live tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now